So I will be discussing now targeting calreticulin and MPNs.
These are my disclosures.
So calreticulin, quick update, a quick background.
It is mutated in 20% to 30% of patients with ET and myelofibrosis.
Calreticulin protein is a protein that's present in the endoplasmic reticulum,
and it's a calcium-binding protein.
It acts as a chaperone, so assists in proper folding of proteins,
has a role in calcium homeostasis, and immune-mediated cell death.
It has three domains.
We have the N-terminus, we have the P-domain, and we have the C-terminus.
And if you look at the C-terminus, it has a four-immunoacid area called the K-del area.
That's the area that leads to the localization to the endoplasmic reticulum.
So if I take this K-del area out, the protein will leave the endoplasmic reticulum.
So mutations in calreticulin, two most common mutations,
type 1 and type 2.
Type 1 is 52-base-pair deletion.
Type 2 is 5-base-pair insertion.
And we have additional in-between what we call type 1 and type 2-like mutations.
And all of these mutations lead to a novel C-terminus lacking the K-del motif.
So it leads to the new C-terminus area.
And if you lost the K-del motif, the calreticulin is secreted to the cell surface,
acts as a paracrine hormone, and activates the MIPL or T-po receptor,
and activates the JAK.
That pathway.
And this mutant color protein, you can detect it in plasma from patients
with color-mutating MPNs, but you don't see that with patients
with JAK2 mutations, for example.
So targeting mutant color.
So this is a neoantigen coming to the cell surface.
It's a neoantigen.
So you can target it by vaccines, target it by antibodies,
or cellular therapy with bispecific or CAR-T therapy.
So vaccines, we have three vaccines.
Two of them are published already in ET and MF, but unfortunately,
those two vaccines did not pan out.
They were poorly immunogenic, no clinical or molecular responses.
The third vaccine is under study at Mount Sinai, no reported results yet.
But when you see the results from the first two vaccines, you ask yourself,
what about T-cell exhaustion and MPNs?
Maybe that's why they are poorly immunogenic.
What about antibody modality?
We have INSIGHT-A.
INSIGHT-A, 3.0.
INSIGHT-A, 3.3.989.
I'll call it 9.8.9 antibody.
This is a fully human IgG1 monoclonal antibody that selectively target the mutant calreticline
because of the new C-terminus.
There are two ongoing phase one studies in patients with ET and MF.
So one each in the US and the others are global outside of the US.
For ET patients, it has to be high risk patients with resistance or intolerance
to previous cytoreductive therapy.
In MF, patients have to be intolerant, resistant, or ineligible for JAK inhibitor.
And then later, an arm for patients who were treatment naive, first line randomized
between the antibody plus/minus ruxolitinib was open.
This is an intravenous antibody, and it was a dose escalation phase one.
It started at 24 milligram up to 2,500 milligram, and no dose-limiting toxicities were noted.
So this is the ET study, 55 patients.
You'll see more type one rather than type two, which what we see in practice.
And when you look at the adverse events, overall, 93% of patients still receiving treatment
at the time of the data cut point for the presentation at ASH.
Four patients discontinued treatment, and you look at the most common adverse events, fatigue,
headache, upper respiratory tract infection.
Grade three adverse events, you will see cytopenias, neutropenia, and anemia, but it was,
was mainly in patients who were already on, like concurrently or just were on hydria, like
just stopped hydria.
Interestingly, we did not see grade three thrombocytopenia, although these patients,
for example, have high platelet count, and then you're bringing these platelets to normal,
but they don't go much below normal.
So that was interesting.
Some patients had lipase and amylase elevation, and those were like intermittent transient
without pancreatitis, clinical pancreatitis.
So this is the results.
This is the data about the platelet control.
You will see in patients who had the higher doses, 400 to 2,500, there was more consistent
normalization of the platelet count.
And this is a plot showing that the complete hematologic response, means normalization
of the platelet count, was seen in 83%, and that was durable, means more than 12 weeks
in 46% of patients.
We saw molecular responses, according to the IWG criteria, like VF decrease more than 50%,
and around 30% of patients.
And you can see also the abnormal megakaryocytes in the marrow, the color technically mutated,
were decreased and would increase the color non-mutated megakaryocytes.
So it seems these unmutated megakaryocytes were just sitting there with suppressed and
just increased after treatment, and this is maybe why we did not see grade three thrombocytopenia.
What about the MF?
We have 52 patients treated.
Here you will see more cytopenias than the ETM.
You will see more MF than the ET population, and there were also increased AST and ALTs
noted in 10 patients.
We saw fatigue, we saw arthralgias, we talked about the AST increase, but in general, 86%
of patients still receiving therapy at the time of the cut point.
What about the responses?
You will see treatment responses, and around 30%, they had the spenic volume reduction,
33% more than 35%, also around 39% had symptom improvement, like more than 50% reduction
in the MPN-SAF form.
Patients who were treatment naive had higher responses in the spleen volume reduction and
higher percentage of symptom improvement.
What also was interesting, we saw anemia responses, like in patients who were anemic, you will
see anemia responses.
We saw molecular responses, but it was less pronounced when you compare it to the ET cohort.
We will see over time if this will deepen or not.
Future directions, so the same antibody will have a subcutaneous formulation.
There are two Bispecific in clinical trials, targeting mutant calortecin, binding
mutant calortecin to CD3, Janssen bispecific and Insight bispecific.
There is a CAR-T preclinical model and antibody drug conjugate preclinical.
And thank you.